você pensou que ia sentir falta da minha casa
dizemos que espanhol, mas muitas vezes
sem sancionado amanhã ok ok sua chegada
brasileiro e eu curtimos dois
britânico
ok sim não não não não eles se acomodam como
saccon rigo que é novo porque já é tênia
frase frase do parque de estacionamento cinza de
língua sim não quem sabe se não é notário
milho
sim não posso encomendar com masters
alto-falantes carson xperia
biblioteca os antigos compartimentos ok evo diana se
então simpatia ou companhia para bojan
pátria
muito bem em um aspecto pouco troglodita
nas
quando entra mas entramos escolhemos
shaolin sempre gosta de samos com som é
uma página chamada sa bem ok desde
Seamus 4 na Itália
normalmente cremoso também
como parece chegar até você e quando vai para
veja a impossibilidade do álbum, por exemplo
osea o que foi lekesiz nos copos
recomendo anúncio como liz noise lei come dar
ex
ou pedindo para você assistir aos banners
che re siviero rosales de over caravex
que estudamos fades Lissa que o
possibilidade de dizer como dar desejo s e
sal são muito dele e nós temos um
gelo barulhento alessandro para quem os verde
dificuldade cana e intermediário eu posso
tenha como você seria davis alessandro ita
mbengue eu posso ter durado como o ódio o
beta ben
tínhamos esperanças para aqueles que consideram como
em vez disso foi cair ou número do
palácio não considera ok, pois são
uma indicação em di casano de cada
mil dificuldades falam disso porque cai
de cada vez em seu próprio baixo dado
estou bem ali nas escolas palavela
exceto com os desafios que caem vez o
system va désir qantas palabras non con
sim, eu imediatamente parei ele e ele mesmo um
manera os sapatos são do rei diversificado
risos porque enquanto nós remamos sim
estuda a coisa interessante, mas tem seu próprio
tempo coeso volta demais deficiente
é importante saber que a quem cada
dificuldade rec vai ser é um
rodrigo vivo embora à noite no s dirigido por jean
jacques fesch no microfone desde
caravex que tem um fluido um microfone
ap antonio savarese e agora eles vêm atrás
significando que quando é um faz logo de charny
microfone ou e eu olho com eduardo embora
que passamos o matador então estávamos
ele olha para as ondas de Moisés
é um sonho muito difícil
um pouco difícil uma viagem é do sexo masculino
então eu pareço um pouco menos não um pouco de milho
milho
ok vota otra vez que quando estamos um pouco
um pequeno déficit e quando não vamos e
melhor moda ou microfone cada vez s
perturbação e ceo, por exemplo, agora estou
mostrando uma coisa
nami vantagem tanta ação pantoja
quando você digitou campos e don emilio
um pouco de comida seca física então no curso
mazzini
talvez uma coisa fotos modernas para
microfone e body fashion week faz isso e sim
chamar microfone como eles são chamados
não importe microfones e microfones
quando ligado desligado os alamos devem ser mostrados al
microfone
ok por eduardo sobre mais moses que eu tinha
brasil film press todos usam link já
levou 4 e 6 lajes britânicas podem
canadá mágico
Inglês avançado macedo desgrenhado o suficiente
o tempo tentado vamos tomar senhor cito
com o escudo
Eu rezei e agonismo e pretendo vê-los
o microfone sombra durante isso
fico fava ok se talvez eduardo os temas
para sóbrio gunther lemon sobrero system
link você pode dar entrada de colher segat
raspado e acho que acompanha o
transmissão do youtube ateu cosche liga
agosto contaor amigos são então deuses
preços garimpam minha ex fila g como democrata
match e um exemplo de pronúncia como este
cuidado leva abuso de rock in house pro
núncio para viver pares que freira detém um
progresso é uma entidade, porém, já existe
quando o tempo é estudar alema una
aldeia como você é álbum aziz 4 face
como 6 é conhecido como um ace boys igual a
escolha o palco que um chino grusin correu
feito por gimenez, mas votou nela
tour punta mesco dalida pronunciar sobre
eto'o de pronúncias que de físico ou
apenas álbuns músicas do álbum
especialmente pedras de casa mais comuns
lei estava rodando no cabo não que eu recebo
g trajes e presentes se ovi a vice lane
dinheiro alegado al khalis paparo
aconselhar como separá-los coexistir é
uma incompatibilidade
steve o que faz sentido microfone ok
então você ouve eu digo que eu sou existe
no idioma de gastos agora eles são fixos para
pronúncia e para quem eu acredito em russo
exemplo é muito decidido hoje em uma altitude bem
tudo bem eu sempre faço é e um novo
tateou para pronunciar o princípio evo
passar um ano saint paul hart sempre
nupcial porque nunca há espaço entre mim
quando já observado nos costumes a
idioma
mas além da genética que faz mais e mais
então você não sabe o princípio depende
casarão para estudar e quem sabe cisas que
fernando é que ele tweeta muita experiência
e ensinar inglês é melhor
partilhador português que está a tirar
na universidade ou pelo menos giose idioma
mas para mim e assim por diante, mas estou na ciência
po o exemplo e daisy para fernando os
Português alimenta melhor inglês
Espanhol e eu a crédito disso e desde ex
arquibancada portuguesa e meus filhos na língua
português ten mais deep tongo steinway
filhos enquanto isso eu observo e você já está em
costuma saber ouvir
meu filho rosas espanholas e eu a crédito que
é muito importante em si ser capaz de mais
umas músicas e agora é uma nova tentativa de
pronuncia um teste e aí eu vejo muito em
exílio, mas por enquanto além da fonte que
esse limite de repetição scutari certo
princípio e não seco e da melhor maneira
dominar ou não a maneira online de
estudo e aquele rostan ben scooter um
opinião de fernanda e cher e rodrigo sim
espinhoso mas por favor
de fato, os huskies são baseados em princípio
é um pouco com você, mas você leva a cara um
meu caso inglês é um pouco mais caro
fioccherà leva um fa o principe inglês
meteo car pro não é e borracha mas quem
avalie vários idiomas de postagem
exatamente como losail com nebuloso
melhor foram eles me levaram a 6
pronuncia seis municípios que como é
tomando como se me levar comprar um
sim para a revolta de são pouco zanza, então se
uma importante cúpula bem dislexia
você nos curioso meses, mas é uma situação
que está em inglês
nunca somos três chances e
oportunidade atira nela no scutari inglês
enquanto espiões entram em um mestre fantasiado
Traje inglês, mas televisão em
filme é música vem em um não e
os r não são isso já
sabemos com os exames, mas para colocar vale a pena
mas russo nos um caso, é possível que o
smart fan é pronunciado em inglês
exatamente porque eu temo muito o ovid 80
Inglês sobre opinião crn the iv f
boh eu não sei se isso me ajuda com pronto para
sau mas é uma fantasia atrás la air is a
jogo, mas ninguém sabe quando eu estou lavando
despejo eu estou andando para o parker, mas
que coeso eu estou sempre falando
pretendendo por nós
mas eu estou voando ferrand
só para começar a cantar vai demorar
Holandês significava conselho
fumar
e eu a crédito e eu pareço que sim é você
em dificuldade para pronunciar talvez ele deva
continuar estudando, mas teremos
crescenta ou vocabulário hubble da Sardenha
david dawe idioma lendo cuspindo e
tantos professores de polis
1 porque agora tem dificuldade em pro
ninguém sabe é um fator de desânimo
e desânimo interior e é negativo e
fica melhor e eu sou um quando eles estudam não
me para mitos e design e conheça o design
imago 9 desencorajado por um novo
pronuncia evo para levar a bola a frança com
la iervolino e como é margarida a fernanda
importante não ter nem astoi e é apreciado
fa lar como fase para é muito
importante em fase para o que ele escreveu que
eu sou fundamentos becks o que é agulha
fase de estradas se essas coisas para fazer em
mismo ben fava sivo 6 costa dell air
ruby como eu caso no começo true
pivot sente-se angustiado e um pouco
frustrado com dificuldades reais
máscara de pronúncia era aquela de tirar alema
e se eu chievo ou não se ele continuar a tomar
eu e festa
talvez se acima da polis porque não somos
um tempo aberto aprendendo a língua
federal estava preparando uma bomba aberta
de tempo e então é tão certo nova
pronunciado você é tão coloca no meio e
mail mail aconselhamento não não se for
útil ou não
ok os outros pré montas acima ou abre em
desconforto
wellink sim não você pode continuar estes
cassano da biblioteca que aconteceu que
das músicas que karim participa
cobre para mim é uma compreensão de como funciona
e eu sempre google plus porque eu sou
convidado para tholos e a quem temo cinco
equipe da igreja personas em resumo, se isso
soros que ontem você não participou
destruído e ou convidá-lo para o mundo do casamento
porque o tempo e são xadrez e quer
participar
não não sei se ok aperta pra quem gosta de desia
e na página
no topo da página para obtê-los não deve
morre também quem tem que fazer mousse sabe
desejos não se tornam dificuldades
vai para mim se alguma rede para cheirar
biblioteca e serviços e decidir a quem é
do que para banners que ele está aprendendo
estudando ou novas velas aprendidas desde
eles são seus sonhos e não era que não é
uma questão de nível e uma questão
que descobre os sóis que ele estava projetando
estudando bob vamos para mudar para
biblioteca em tambay e na página de
pegue tudo talvez exploda versus
vários lomas ingleses distintos
chinês bahrami português eu sou
estudando e tentado feto de 120 a três
como 67 links para me preparar para
a discussão conversa eta beta
in fa trabalha com fernando equa diego
palavras um pouco para preparar por que
fazer em português ok a coisa a
biblioteca e álbum temus tito saindo
biblioteca acima que foi difícil
procurá-los não diz buscar e a quantidade
que eles obtêm mas e desejam
como ser funcional e sempre em falta
mapa ssa misma mustaine biblioteca ove
biblioteca aberta minias ominia lin
músicas para importar festas temáticas
mudança para a tradição portuguesa porquê
ou seja, um também está mudando iso é
basta escrever importações
porque se não você, então se é verdade
como concerto novas uma biblioteca de desculpas
sketch que já paga como isso é
styling está dando um choque que ele usava
e, em seguida, a facilidade de procuração para procuração i
seu pouco de tê-lo é uma coluna protética
teste um pantoja para o quênia porque não o
agentes prolongados que preferiram por sms
esta manhã os evos e a cidade ea
biblioteca, mas sempre parece ter decidido
presente explica cassano de sass di
da mesma forma
tambay talvez você possa sony ou cursores
que é um curso consiste em um 69 dos
músicas e quando criamos o conteúdo como
por exemplo para frear h
que sempre criou o lissoni português
e no topo da competição com 20 liszt sony e
nunca disperso para usar use ser
lissonesi está comendo organizado e
não corro mas tenho medo stan ben filho do som
listas de reprodução ou que você cria desejo e ou para
exemplo eu posso escutar as músicas para quem
incluiu sony sóis em um
playlist ou ou exemplo se estou
adquirir uma biblioteca de pesos o que você faz
interessante que não usuário tenho tempo
para csto de Aragão eu posso colocar não é nem
um futuro jogador profissional uma lista de reprodução acima
lissoni sovra economia ou lista de reprodução ou isso
se é main fernandez quem esta ajudando
dando-lhe nós pedimos em
Português pode sempre ser ou
playlist de fernanda para
iniciantes, por exemplo, dentro é um
em verdade livros os penhascos de lissoni
consumismo ou então posou tiros ayudar
outros links e de mim para digitar não posso então
adquirir sites com a caixa de pesquisa
economia para nós não e economia milhões não
tem arroz e lata ok mas normalmente
compras usando ele funciona bem
a hora de importá-los é e pronto
voz alessi
estudar uma lição que vem que
fornes fornecidos por e do ponto inglês
com
talvez apenas técnicas de carros cli
acima de um nome nome do exame de telefone maluco
uma coisa para quem temus gesticula buscarsi o
nombre de palerme novas dura são
do áudio ou por exemplo segue foi sentido
entalhes americanos britânicos que vêm dele
histórias funciona na corrida quando voa
procuração em biblioteca portuguesa
posso estar errado ii soul ii soul goleiro
porto de portugal destes próprios
ok do nas que você está acima da biblioteca e
egpc e ou pior
lapresse na música velasco espanhola
de acordo com tosi na porta o esp e como tem
dúvidas acima estes são seis lugares
reconcilia com todo mundo o quase post
comprar cilia com amigo jogo alto
apostas
ok use você sente tanto eu temo a possibilidade
del dei compartti al le canções mais a
capacidade de importar músicas e
membros que pagam por ônibus que não
pagando um limite do item de sincronização
artigos só importavam, mas osman
bruce que paga algum major em
quanto pede que possamos somar
compartimentos compartimentos de uma biblioteca
coesa cena ou dez
limites do ponto de vista do reiter
autor
ok désir você queria, por exemplo, um
periódico em princípio não detém direto
com compartimentos brancos todo o que era
enquadrado enquanto médias e deve para
apto ou dono e muito tenso e
elogie o caso do mysims sem resposta porque é
o problema é um problema não vai romper
em suma, tanto isso e nunca, por exemplo
hotel contado na wikipedia
i ris designo itam bay fernanda pre
contou um podcast em portugal e é
tanto si é o exemplo do café de moscou de
zero após fernando prorrogado mas ambos em alta
paolo no fernando uma libra não não
lembre-se de pérolas silvianas a
tiro cruzado e stephen t rex kharja
atrás de um caminho o moscou i sóis
fantástico e na casa está na língua da casa e
um pré contado talvez possamos usar
e se então o gás est et a matera no
nossa biblioteca e deuses
um podcast de rádio que dos sentidos obrigado e
desenho e ideias que ele diz não responder
mas em princípio ele deve votar sim se não
a outra idade todos os compartimentos um
biblioteca na interpol que eu quero usar
usá-lo ou consumismo importante para usar, mas
i tam bel po o compacto compart l'iran
o ing quando ele queria lhe dar uma rosa o
ds muito dos segmentos de guarda explica
mente como uma indicação de curinga
home artigo artigo é nosso
sistema não se sabe se eu sou um e real
artigo, posso importá-lo imediatamente
qualidade era a possibilidade de
link lento do membro do mythos ou artigo do mismo
mas não é uma biblioteca
OK ok ok
agora desista embora o tempo de importação
mansão dos meninos é importante, mas e eco
pérola e kolar e além é uso ou em
então doc malware que é milho rápido e
benefícios de tempo que já tudo incluído
mais incluindo o fluido incluído veio
quando ele queria importar usando o
bookmarklet talvez você simplesmente não queira copiar
articulação ou área, mas você queria com o
copiar artigo articulado para para
polo está acontecendo na cidade 6 bem, tente isso
cópia conjunta e com fio agora fechada entre
escolas e setores compactos estão em lisa
máximo de 6 usos ou um pouco de microfone bot e nunca
espaço não é que seu pós-mercado é
você não acha que não é um fúcsia que foi
deve no ar na tuba e clique de voz
sobre uma cruz e ou isca se você alugar
vagabundo clegg pago para virar
import ou porque eu já era minha mídia e
eu saio lido e para marcar e 9, mas deixou claro
que eu mantenho para limpar bem o lugar do Canadá
Estado Dourado
adebayor ok agora não estou conectado
próprio sistema
sem algumas bebidas no gotejamento hoje e
marco vislumbrado mais tarde se destacam, mas um
bar não é um navegador e você não é muito
como Nápoles Bonzi Roma que o povo de
físico obtê-los ok, mas é muito
sempre bom uso quando estou tendo um
bom álbum periódico para o que
parte interessante curso muito rápido
importante nas importa para isso vai
nos estados que você conhece pouco é sério com
exemplo sempre ok compartilhar tela vamo a
centro cultural eurostar para estudar oa
New York Times para ser como a tela
mulheres poupadoras
New York Times ok para quem eu temo no novo
york times ou abra um artigo e ou sim e
a quem europeu jean bookmarklet a quem ok
evo click e você seleciona qual
vídeo mas para quem é inglês muito bem
porque é um dispositivo quando enci arco
em russo em sino japonês lo que ser
pole para aqueles que inglês muito bem você
importante e no artigo
o eixo vai abrir já na liga e para quem tem
você tem a oportunidade de escolher
onde e ceo euro subfundos
alessio é produzido em smembri delic pol en
studart se perguntou eu incluo sim sim
evidentemente sendo apenas sim que
argo cônsul santanchè que reaparece
copie a banda tam copie ou link para
Eu odeio no entanto a quem não é que eu não odeio
impede que, além de estar em mim e como ex
rocker são baseados em navegador e por que quantos
kathleen weiss e import marco min
versão descartada um texto antigo de karen
marcador não s foi você primeiro sabe o que é
permanecer envergonhado arenque respeito
preso largamente a quem
você sabe quem eu temo ok bookmarklet engine un
navegador a partir de concurso menos navegador
caso use ou selecione mater não
exceto alguns navegadores
ok você não é a primeira coisa e é o único para
me é como você pode usar você coloca
em vez de um navegador com algum mapa, mas
você é uma parte acontece com quem é porque eles são
apresentando o tempo schleck não
Mudar completo para o pai, mas ele já está lá, mas
é um não coberto porque é um feto que é
que permite parar por alargar e
agora sempre use um marcador theo akin
e isso é o suficiente para mim, isso é o suficiente
não não depois da página de ajuda que muda o
leva agora não eu não sou surdo voto
linha de assinatura vintage contextual sim
mostra os custos de kukan por barra ainda que
no coconato votamos para inflar
um artigo que responde que
a insurreição da fusão linguística em
função que você projeta memorando stu darcos tem
escrito na textura da mente 76, então se em
Eu odeio os outros mais experientes
página para página quem para paginar a lista o
quando como sementes nov eles têm micose
membros que não gostam eu vou 9 sistemas
porque era uma fantasia de peugeot
sistema não, mas talvez nenhum medo tente com um
eu continuo me acostumando a pasin com wawrinka
como é que mantemos mantemos ou sistema
com alguns porquês para quem não trabalha
você sabe que estou preso, pare, mas funciona
porque para quem eu sou forma tradicional
Deixo o país para quem está de dieta e com ela
texto esportivo ou rímel me incomoda
porque quando aquele advogado ou textura e
tambay e euro milho latindo acima
exemplo e arroz tolo que controla quem, mas
segundo aprendeu a software entendido que
eu e eu computador para efetuar algo
quem está pd porque normalmente para quem
advertir minimizado minimiza tailandês
boxe, mas quem não pediu bom
Eu conheço a lista da primeira página 1
amigo sóbrio sistema de três funções ou aquele
essa linguagem surpreendente algo não para um
verdade de um suposto milho geral que
você conhece 8 parceiros de engajamento de conteúdo
e que visualizam inglês espanhol português
que restaura uma contagem contínua
sergio pezzota conjunto de hideo sia
para instyle juntos ou jesus eram válidos
Eu não entendo que você disse que demos
você vários idiomas cidade ou homem e os riscos a
camarada de sass tema confessa aposta
perdedor como otis você pensa em esponja e
venha e vá continuar eles poderiam vender
e nos mostre que havia o sistema um
experiência
parah parah comparação prática com ser
sistema de tempo sadun do google plus hangouts
massa para cheirar por exemplo é fazer
convivem pessoas cada vez que subornos que
não residentes
dos cálculos do início que iremos
continuaremos a usar o google plus será o
nova cara e estampa para se comunicar
membros para explicar o sistema de parentesco
nder pronto azedo só conta que eu sou
bom que aquele osnabruck en v phase room
converse harman hanaut semana
próximo em mandarim i
tambay esse depende do tempo esse tempo
do que ver você na próxima semana
começa em manago e quatro diferentes em
dialeto conhecido em um tempo no entanto que remus
palco que facilita a comunicação do som não
Eu sei que eles entram e marrom e ou vida de membro
enquanto um membro sofre e nós estamos
experimentando com diferentes tiros do sistema
para o qual a massa do sistema massas falsas
agora seu tiro é impreciso que eu estava
no entanto, continuar na forma e técnica
como a mesquita elisa ass.te e que a
embora tambay mostre que hughes afirma
experimenta em três turismo ter hanoun
pá interagir talento em mismos desde
você agora é só tecnologia ma ninos dei
cassano comum que coloca eu não sei coloca
criar uma comunidade interativa e milho
fase do milho se ama né lotito
ponto de vista noturno
tener didático e seu caminho é
o que a musa escreve para descobrir e o que não
então nós cronometramos, em suma, uma ideia fixa
o que é certo é que ele é um poeta, você sabe o que há
melhor para abrir em cinza você sabe se
se filmes para ou para receber ou podcasts
tese e sempre eu você pensa que eu tendo e
comércio
uma coisa, porém, é que tomar um idioma
é campo de golfe preciso não são decididos
que custos eu faço, mas é pro sisal preciso
que consiste em nós atividades as guias são
fazer com isso era que custava
estande de cinema que compareceu ao fim
como um contato é muito importante
com ou milho idiom tempo que passa
com expressões idiomáticas de coelho, mas melhor vice-
leva no entanto prensas por causa de filmes
paraíso difícil filme muito difícil
eu gostaria de 9 anos sem então durante
dificuldades de registro de depósito notas lá
falará sobre a loja onde está localizada e
Japonês no entanto mantemos suas dificuldades
da equipe comprender o senhor Mons
filme filho milho dificil e eu preferia
ele preferiu examiná-los porque o tempo admite
palavras palavras imagem e para miti e eu
a crédito que esmer ur para para
legitimamente eu pretendo creditar isso
deixou
o aprendiz de línguas e o
Vocabulário como sempre Diego
e eu credito essa camada e ouço e
milho eficiente você toma ensaios de
paula che hospira mons mas de filmes é
uma mãe negra do golfo a caminho do
milho navegador e milho picada de simon
Atividade de milho fluido e trabalho sou eu
bem, eu me importo com você que é Mikasa Teo
filmes do desapontado tcheco e thangram sentenciam um
noemi rai português sistemas não rfid
vivo verde para ter sua assinatura embora para
aprenda com filiais e scooters áreas verdes
i falchi e film josè como is like a
recompensa dos testes de estresse que tenho
fez o tempo plano que parecia levá-lo
idiom minus é uma ferramenta do
previsão
mas agora os machos e além disso estamos
opinião documental
ok eu muito obrigado rais assistido
capa e status se disco discutido e um
pousar um vizinho agora que ele é o próximo
vejo você na próxima vez